In this lesson, we'll talk about
multimedia and streaming. We'll talk about digital
audio and video data, multimedia applications, in
particular, streaming audio and video for playback.
Multimedia transfers over a best-effort network,
in particular, how to tolerate packet loss
delay and jitter, and quality of service.
So we use multimedia and streaming video
very frequently on todays internet. YouTube streaming
videos are an example of multimedia streaming
as are applications for video or voice chat such as Skype or Google Hangout.
In this lecture we'll talk about the
challenges for streaming these types of applications
over best effort networks. As well has how to solve those challenges. We'll also
talk about the basics of digital audio and video data.
First of all, let's talk about the challenges for media streaming.